hallways
ones bustling with student activity
are now quiet
it's only days since public university
teachers in nigeria walked off their
jobs but lecture halls are already
covered with dust
the government has expressed surprise
but the lecturers are unmoved
they can say they are surprised because
they are not serious
i'm sure nigerians are no surprise
because we didn't wake up overnight and
said that we are going on strike 13
years ago educators and the government
signed an agreement to end an epidemic
of strikes at nigerian universities but
teachers say this was never implemented
in the past 20 years there have been
nearly as many strikes by academic staff
in nigerian universities the industrial
dispute has disrupted academic calendars
as a result students sometimes take six
to seven years to complete a four-year
degree program
these students come to the university
nearly every day hoping for positive
news
they hope to to graduate and
and to get job
now we don't even have that kind of
thinking
but his peers in private universities
have no such worries
federal government has almost a 100
university and they have so many
challenges ahead of them in our own when
you view a private university naturally
your focus must be on the
the institution
years of neglect have left public
universities overcrowded and with poor
funding for research and salaries
union leaders say most professors earn
less than a thousand dollars a month
lecturers say they are tired of meetings
and agreements that the government fails
to implement
they warn in one month they will make
this strike indefinite if there is no
breakthrough
ahamad idris
nigeria